this is an important announcement
especially if you live in Los Angeles I
am shooting my special Wednesday
December 14th at the dynasty typewriter
theater here in Los Angeles uh tickets
are available on my website right now at
ryansickler.com and here's the deal
if you use code sickler and I'm telling
you specifically you all because you all
are the die hards if you use code
sickler you're getting half off your
tickets all right so uh we're gonna do
two shows Wednesday December 14th go
snag those tickets up now I want a
loaded house let's have a great time
bringing an end to this night pants
Nation Tour for the special that you
guys will see uh very soon hopefully
Chicago I'll be there November 11th and
12th Grand Rapids Michigan December 9th
and 10th get your tickets to those shows
and all shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and I want to say thank you
thank you to everybody who watches this
show thank you to everyone who messages
me thank you for all of your support if
you are watching on YouTube please hit
the Subscribe button it means everything
to us we had a big jump you guys are
listening and it helps out big time so
thank you for doing that and if you
gotta have more then you gotta check out
the patreon Honeydew with y'all where
I'm highlighting the low lights with
y'all and I say it every week y'all got
the wildest [ __ ] stories I've ever
heard in my life it is five dollars a
month if you sign up for your year you
get over a month free and you get the
Honeydew a day early you get it ad free
at no additional cost all right if you
or someone you know has a story that has
to be heard please submit it to honeydew
pop podcast gmail.com and hopefully we
get to do an episode together all right
the night pants Nation Tour continues
thank you to everyone out there who's
bought a ticket who's come out who's
seen me live Chicago I will be there
November 11th and the 12th Grand Rapids
December 9th and the 10th all right
that's the biz right there y'all now you
know what we do over here we highlight
the low lights I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
I'm very excited to have this guest on
today first time here on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Jackie fabulous welcome to the Honeydew
Jackie you startled me when you began
yell at me I get excited for my job
but I couldn't stop laughing about it
oh well welcome welcome to the show
thank you for being here thank you for
having me I
I thought it'd be what it is now
it is now one day and then I thought to
myself this is all confidence I'm like
we're not gonna probably say yes because
I we I've always gotten the vibe from
you I'm like okay cool I don't know what
it is you gotta Just Vibe with someone
yeah you see them three times and I'm
like we've never spent more than three
and a half minutes together but
we good every time everything's all
right I don't know what it is well um
thank you for that and thank you for
being here thank you for having me I
love your shirt thank you I love it and
your nails everything's looking good hey
this is merch and I wasn't too lazy to
bring to any show plug it plug
everything you want right now you're
you're what is that Jackie fabulous your
Instagram yeah all my social medias at
Jackie fabulous website Jackie
fabulous.com
buy all my crap learn who I am come to
my shows all that updates are there my
dates are there and I haven't updated
I'm at DC comedy log September 1st or
the 3rd okay my comedy album just came
out uh it's on everywhere you can buy an
album and my comedy special of the same
name menopause I like it came out I'll
tell you what all right I'm going to the
change life you know we're all gonna die
me probably before do you mind telling
us how young you are I'm 50. I'll be 51
August 12th college girl cash out oh you
look good
it's Jack's family
you'll find me just look it up don't be
lazy and um I sweat sometimes and go
through the change of hot flashes while
I'm performing and I didn't know that
would happen because it all happened
during the lockdown that lights and
stuff making me dispersed in the Flames
okay so I was in Rhode Island I forget
comedy connection Rhode Island is that
where that is I was doing a weekend
there I told the audience just so you
know I sweat I'm going through the claws
and this man started applauding in the
back so I was like like you you
applauding for uh menopause and he said
I'm giving you men Applause
that's great so I said first of all I'm
taking that I'm not giving you a goddamn
down not a penny so that's why I'm like
catchy it's catchy so yeah that's my
title of my album and special menopause
on Amazon Apple TV all the other ones
and all the ones except you know you
know yeah
the one the one the one actually one of
the ones I've let go of that being the
Holy Grail I want to be there of course
but if not as long as I'm working well
the Holy Grail is just putting it out
there I'm working on mine now too and
honestly like you know if you look at
back in the day we all wanted to kill
one another to get on this one network
called Comedy Central yes because there
was only one [ __ ] Network that
said this is what we think it's funny
and listen here's the thing they weren't
wrong everybody put on there was funny
but there's more than 20 people there's
more than 20 [ __ ] comedians out
there got so many meetings with them too
right over the years and it's always no
throwing snow day they like who they
like and that's fine yeah and after a
while it's like we're gonna send them
over the wall but you all aren't gonna
get over the wall and the whole time
we're over here like man I know I'm good
too yeah again not saying better than
anybody else but I know I'm just
understand they always I was always told
with them is that I wasn't part of the
demographic who watches the show you
know woman Black full fig at over 40 and
then I'm like well haven't you had like
a lot of love on there but it really is
not if you look at who watches it's
white guys between this that yeah it's
College Fresh yeah and that's who they
made their shows for that was when
Daniel Tosh was you know the height of
the show Amy Schumer had a joint on
there so I got it I still wanted to get
a special you know a half hour 20
minutes and that would apply and they
would just say no no no and I know they
like me I know we know it's my thing in
the business they all know who we are of
course well our names will never come
across the table they're like who they
all know us but you have to wait until
it's your turn that's basically my whole
career just work hard and wait your turn
create your own opportunity and while
you wait and that's what we all do
create your own [ __ ] so then here comes
a company like Netflix that says well we
think this is funny and then Here Comes
Amazon Here Comes Hulu and here's
YouTube where we all just go with none
of y'all gonna [ __ ] with me I'm gonna
put my [ __ ] over here and people are
having wild successes yes
yeah
and I remember during I remember during
the quarantine lockdown in my in the
bedroom I'm in my childhood bedroom when
I grow up and don't have my own place
yet when we were all in our bedrooms
kind of wondering about our lives and is
this going to be it am I gonna die I
watched my comedian uh co-workers put up
their specials and now they're on the
road calendar days out there [ __ ]
they're doing their third special now I
watched them post it and I'm like okay
let's see how this works out instead of
like why don't you just pay somebody
with a camera and go on rooftop and
close your own goddamn joke and it
didn't care it occurred to me but
laziness you know no confidence I'm
assuming I'm like a white guy he
probably got the funds to do this all
kind of doubting myself I all I had to
have was somebody with a camera and time
so you just said something about being
in your childhood bedroom yes so all
right we're gonna lead up to that let's
go back to the beginning where are you
from originally where is this childhood
Home Bronx New York down all right
um childhood home it's in the Bronx I
lived in New York up until age 29 and I
moved to LA in 2000 when I turned 30 and
I moved to LA to go to law school really
yes because no law school my LSAT and
test taking skills are horrible so I had
a really low score so I'm like any
school that will let me in the building
I will go so I applied to random schools
all over the country just saying please
somebody say that because they all said
no and uh one small school in La said
yes you can come out here contingent
upon passing this test blah blah blah I
failed the test transferred to another
school a Christian Law School in
California called Trinity law school
they let me stay finishing four years
got the degree and it looked and got
married while I was out there also I
left my boyfriend in New York and moved
to LA to go to law school and when he
followed me because he didn't believe me
I was leaving until like pack my [ __ ]
and left and then he followed me a
dramatic soap opera with eloped I
divorced him less than a year later but
finished law school and uh then I just
dragged day jobs and working and that
led to you know where I am now but I in
the Bronx I'm living with my retired
Jamaican mom just me and her in the
house that I grew up in dad died five
years ago and I'm sorry oh thank you and
I'm engaged so I'm in that place where
I'm like do I get a place now do I wait
till we get married do I get a job where
I can even afford to live in New York so
I'm in that very delicate area of I
don't know what the [ __ ] is gonna happen
tomorrow
I have no idea what I'm doing yeah but
I'm doing it anyway yeah that's my life
right that's it every day you get up and
you just go yep there's nothing else you
can do there's not I have no when I tell
you every morning I'm like no [ __ ]
idea who's gonna call me email me will I
get a job well they say we we thought we
were gonna do that but we're gonna we
had to change the plan every day is an
emotional I have no [ __ ] clue so all
I can do is just get my nails done and
keep my eyelashes nice and long and just
hope for the best well it's working
thank you
um all right so how many are you your
mom and dad are
um from where originally Jamaica
everybody's Jamaica yes I'm first
generation Americans I was born in the
Bronx so they came here from Jamaica is
that where they met in Jamaica yeah my
dad was a a cop in Kingston Jamaica my
mom I don't know where she did they're
very vague about their life when they
were younger but they dated and I think
he moved to America First and he was
like a porter in a hospital you know get
any job you can't immigrant and then
when he got settled I think he sent for
her and she moved here and was a nanny
in Cleveland this their love story
sounds very complicated it was just a
matter of we broke we immigrants we just
came here there's no big romance besides
that and then they then they got married
and I was born in 71 they bought a house
I've always had a working class
upbringing hard-working people everybody
had a job are you an only child I have a
sister she's 11 years younger than me
just turned 40. and just got her
Master's in social work from Hunter
College so all right shout out to
Jessica champagne and same parents yeah
why are you on oops baby I don't know I
remember before she was born bugging
them because I was lonely and they were
they kept saying no by the time they
were like sure I was like 11 and I was
like I don't want nobody now but you
know that's not bad yeah yo that window
I'm starting to get titties they got my
period when I was 11. I'm like why are
you on the side to do this now
selfish [ __ ]
that's exactly how it went then I became
the babysitter of course it's probably
bitter probably of course that's
probably why I low-key always have a
problem with my sister because I'm like
you [ __ ] my life up but I would die
for you now that's all that matters
too much okay and did your parents Stay
Together were they together the whole
yes they were married 50 years or more
my dad passed away yes wow they made it
to 5-0
um and what's your relationship like
with your mom ah I would die for her and
I do love her intensely but living with
her is a horrible idea and it's bad for
my mental health and why because I
haven't lived there for 20 years I moved
back uh in October 2020 pre-covis I
moved back with a full touring schedule
plenty of money just working person so
I'm like I'm gonna move back but I'll
get a place in a month or two the rent's
run what they are now and then covet hit
and then I just and covet hit and I
reunited with my boyfriend who lived in
New York so my mental and emotional hell
which is completely bombarded with I'm
surviving and I have a new boyfriend
and you're back in your childhood back
in my bedroom that I grew up in with new
clothes and you know new income but no
room for any of this new sweat posts are
still there okay and a brand new Gucci
bag because I am I'm a failure but I you
know so I'm working on my life talk to
me about this for a minute because all
right I know you went back with the idea
to get a place and and listen New York
here San Francisco three of the most
expensive cities in the [ __ ] world
yeah but I was blessed because you know
you know what a intermediate touring
comic makes so I could afford uh you
know a decent rent in New York but all
that has changed to this day that's like
five grand for a decent place in New
York and I'm like what yeah it was 2500
a couple of months ago yeah so that's
why I'm like could I afford it I
probably could but do I want to live
like that right strapped to this damn
apartment yeah I don't own it no I don't
own it I probably could have bought a
place if I had done it like
for you exactly so I'm in that place now
I'm like all this transition and so
after 20 years you go back and now
you're in your childhood bedroom and is
it just you and your mom in the house
yeah yeah in this big old house and she
won't let me make it comfortable that's
part of why I'm uncomfortable this you
won't let me throw things away and
there's a spare bedroom that could be my
closet slash office she won't let me
touch anything uh a full-size bed and
clothes my clothes a lot of storage of
my my bookcase that I had with all of my
[ __ ] Judy Bloom [ __ ] books and all
that still there and my father's stuff
everywhere khakis 807 pairs of plenty of
different khakis
everywhere it's like a memorial and
everyone every railing of his pants his
his shorts he has a hanging over his
baseball caps
it's just a [ __ ] Memorial of my
father
trucker hats baseball hats Cricket oh he
was umpire so she won't allow me to make
the house me and her so
so you know so I'm while I'm very
blessed to have a wonderful Clean safe
big ass house to live in I'm still very
uncomfortable so I'm working in right
now I'm getting a full-time job in
entertainment so that I could get the
[ __ ] out of the house does it trip you
out to be back in your childhood uh room
it did in the beginning now it's just
I'm always aggravated like I'm trying to
lead you with appreciation and gratitude
with all that comes out of my mouth is
what the [ __ ] am I still doing here so
Riley with gratitude the Gratitude will
get you out of there but this gratitude
was last I'm a [ __ ] failure so but I
know that I'm not you know you are
definitely not well I need to move and
I'm really really in love and I want I
want us to have our own place to walk to
be to be naked in our houses yeah like
when we can afford it he'll travel with
me on road gigs at long ones and we'll
be in the hotel room like my God why
can't we live together this is we are
old
he's 51 yeah so I'm like shouldn't we be
in her own crib and he's like yeah but
you know he he's on a fixed income so
I'm the one that would have to like help
us most of them plays nice and then we
contribute together but I can't move
right now I just can't afford it
and are you watching this is something
people have talked to me about to aging
parents and stuff so are you sort of
caretaking as well or is your mom in
good health right now I'm not gonna am I
caretaking the way I should to be honest
she's I think she's going to be 80 or 79
years old she doesn't tell me what's
going on I don't know why they think I
don't care but when she has a new
ailment or issue or needs a new
prescription it's all a secret like for
example I was I went I was at the
getting my hair done last week I was
under the dryer deep conditioning and my
phone rang and my aunt said hey your mom
will not be there to pick up the amazon
grocery delivery she's going under
anesthesia and I'm like I'm going under
anesthesia for what yeah and she's like
she's having a procedure she's having
some shots in her hip because she has
her sciatica and her back all kind of
issue with walking so I'm like why you
why am I finding out now that she's
going under anesthesia and she's like
well you're not the one like you know
when we won't be there and I'm like so
this has happened on a regular basis
because my mother is lucky she has my
aunt her sister who lives in the
apartment downstairs so them two are
codependent so I don't get told much
because there are little cohorts
together right so I'm really outside I'm
the outside and my sister is also with
them so all I say now is look if
somebody dies at least let me know
that's all I can do at this point I
tried I tried to have my name put on the
deed to make the house mine because
they're old as [ __ ] and they're like you
thought you would have thought I was
asking them to murder them permission to
I'm like no no I'm just trying to move
us along because you are not Immortal
yeah even though I might die tomorrow
let's let's be real y'all are gonna go
first let's get this taken care of but
that's what I'm dealing with every day
and I'm not taking care of them the way
I should because mentally I can't as
long as those two can handle it just let
me know when you need money and need a
ride I got a reliable new car I make
enough money that if you need whatever
for this I can hopefully take care of it
beyond that I have to take care of my
own mental health that's too much going
on as long as everyone's okay right
everybody is well okay outside we were
talking and uh you said something about
your attitude toward death why don't you
tell me a little more about that my
father died five years ago and I guess
part of it was part of it is
um he's always been there like every day
of my life until I moved out but he's
been there in terms of paying the bills
he didn't take me anywhere I didn't
confide in me or teach me much because
I've learned everything pretty much by
trial and error but I I'm like on the on
the front side I'm like well you're
grown you know walk it off the daddy
issues you fix it on the other side I'm
like well that's partially why I'm also
like if you want if you are not in my
life in a productive daily or monthly or
weekly way when you pass how sad am I
supposed to be you know so he I know
would die for me and he always will be
there for me when he was alive when he
passed away I'm kind of like well he was
also depressed I could tell because he
was financially strained his whole
marriage and slash with his two kids
didn't have any money but he kind of
fronted like he did lives on credit I
didn't know that until I started to see
the paperwork when he passed like oh you
guys maintain all this we're just
maintaining very good credit for decades
you know the nice cars the the house I
was always cute and with private school
but it's all based on credit and then
maintaining a job so they had to work
they could never not work so learning
all that and knowing why he was probably
a depressed guy didn't really involve
himself in my life too much because he
saw that I was okay despite me not
having any real Parental Guidance I
turned out fantastic but so when he died
I'm like he did his job I'm cool he
loved my mom the best he could I didn't
I turned out me and my sister you know
no problems no drugs no kids everywhere
we're really a success so when he died
I'm like well he did his job he had an
assignment so I didn't I was sad because
I'm like oh my God my mother's husband
I'm more like that I got more sad about
that like her man her man gone that's
when I took it out of Jackie her daddy
died but was it your daddy or was it
your father but I'm like oh but her dude
is is gone her partner her best friend
her Confidant that's what made me make
me sad not me losing him is her you know
but once again I'm also like he was also
in pain I could tell he had a disease
that wasn't curable and it was making
him weak because I could tell in his
eyes he wanted to go like he gave me one
of his rings that I wear in pictures
every now and then a beautiful gold ring
and when I took it that I'm like it'll
probably be mad and be like put it back
he was like no no
you can wear it and something on when
that moment I'm like
he probably no felt that he was on his
way to let and he took my mother to
teach her how to do this this was a car
and change the oil give her all these
lessons weeks before and I'm like that's
all in my mind of God saying get your
paperwork together
it's about to go down so I feel like he
he was um ready in some weird way
so I look at death kind of like when
people go no matter how they go you know
it's uh I'm gonna cry with this one this
happened last night oh I don't have to
give tissue no I'm gonna cry let's get
some tissues
I'm crying for this one this
one this is why I don't do podcasts
here come the tissue I
shout out to uh
thank you thank you Kirsten shout out to
us
last night I did Flappers uh eight
o'clock uh Tony Baker and friends I did
his show and I know new is gonna be sold
out because it's Tony so I made sure I
look extra cute you know and I'm like
okay I'm mentally ready to perform
because I get nervous because I know
it's his crowd and then but I also know
that I have not seen his face or talked
to him live since his son passed right
so I'm also like but you're Jackie you
and Tony cool but y'all ain't tight
you're very cool very very cool but
you're not the best of friends you live
in two different Coast you don't see
each other anymore on the road in the
circle because we're two different
career paths same job with different
career paths so when I saw him and I
walked in the Green Room his little
slappers he was sitting there and it
just kind of hit me that I have not seen
him and then behind him his shoulder
moved I saw the face his other son and
I'm like oh are your son high and I just
felt like oh my God I did not grieve or
I didn't I didn't send them flowers I
didn't call I didn't I had no idea what
I didn't do
so when um
I watched the show he did his set every
time I was second to last
he introduced me I got on stage and when
I got on stage and looked out I just
felt I couldn't remember what I wanted
to say
I couldn't get the joke out it was a
horrible set by my standards his son was
in the front row and I don't know you
know why I was so sad I barely knew his
son but I realized that I didn't do
anything when he passed besides you know
fellow you know commenting on Instagram
or whatever so I just felt sad and then
I had to I had to wash off the side to
do the set I'm like okay this is you're
in your own head Tony will be fine he'll
he you know he'll be he got a family of
his own so I did the step I did this
outside of my body I didn't feel like I
was there I wasn't in my groove
so when I was done yeah
the show ended I hugged him goodbye and
I laughed but I just I've been sad ever
since I don't know why
the way his son passed it was terrible
oh
anyway
that's what I that's with death that
kind of thing bothered me because I get
regret when I don't have Consulting
people who didn't want a child yeah the
child the way he masked and how I kind
of I can sense when somebody has sadness
in them and even though Tony is very
good at being Tony I can still you know
his side I could tell and his friends
Keenan was in the green room and I could
just kind of feel they're heavy but
forever now forever so ah so that was uh
that but
when it comes to death it happens
naturally I have a very I think a
healthy attitude I'm like if it's age or
God forbid disease I'm like well you
know hopefully I die in a way that comes
gradually I want to be a sassy old lady
with the gray hair I want to be
bedazzled
I want to have that glass of scotch on
the porch of my house you know I want to
grow old but I want to be healthy but if
God takes me just because I just you
know I've lived it out and I think
that's healthy but when you die in the
way that you know he died then I'm like
oh God I don't you know I just feel
consumed with heaviness and it's not
even and I'm not part of their lives I
don't know what happened but I was part
of our community yes you know and one of
our
you know brotherhood's son Beyond I mean
that's true and and the
the senseless way that poor boy at the
all the you know what all those children
they all died in that car oh yeah
everyone in the car the girl all that so
Thursday night I've got Lamar thrown for
more than 200 yards Mahomes is rushing
for more than 35 yards and I got Aaron
Rodgers throwing for more than 300 yards
prize picks format it's simple it's easy
to understand so even if you aren't a
sports fanatic you can still play and
have fun you pick two to five players
and if they will score more or less than
their prize picks projection all right
you can win up to 10 times your money on
any entry and you are never competing
against other people it's just you
versus the projections available and
there are projections for any sport you
watch NFL NBA MLB NHL PGA college
football college basketball soccer
WNBA Esports y'all NASCAR tennis MMA
boxing disc golf Euro basketball cricket
and more entries can be made in 60
seconds or less they're safe and fast
withdrawal and it's currently
operational in over 30 States and Canada
download the prize picks app or go to
prize picks.com to sign up and play
daily fantasy sports first time users
can receive a hundred percent instant
deposit match up to 100 with promo code
honeydew if you deposit 100 prize picks
gonna give you a hundred dollars if you
deposit 50 prize picks will give you 50.
don't forget to enter promo code
honeydew at your sign up for an instant
deposit match up to one hundred dollars
whether you're prepping for the day or
you're taking a long-haul flight on
vacation or on work y'all liquid IV is
an essential addition to your routine
every morning when I go to the gym I
drop a liquid IV in my water bottle boom
I take it I'm staying hydrated at the
gym Kirsten's always rocking them on our
flights I'm here for everybody at the
studio and we're running low to be
honest with you one stick of liquid IV
and 16 ounces of water hydrates you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone it contains five essential
vitamins you're getting B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C it's got three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's made with premium
ingredients non-GMO and free from gluten
dairy and soy to date liquid IV is
donated over 25 million servings in 50
plus countries around the world grab
your liquid IV and bulk nationwide at
Costco or get 15 off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use code honey do a
checkout that's 15 off of anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid iv.com now let's get back to the
do is that the first
um sort of death you've dealt with like
that have you ever been impacted by any
other significant death in your life my
ex-husband he had a heart attack I was
sad about that because he we weren't
together we were divorced for years when
he passed but when I but we were casual
cook cordial so I will text and talk on
the phone probably shouldn't but we
still did this is the one you eloped
with yeah I looked with him in Vegas in
2000 divorced him less than a year later
but so you were still friendly after he
was still friendly okay and by friendly
I think I wouldn't let go without can I
kind of felt like I [ __ ] up like oh I
probably should try to work it out with
this dude okay so I would stay I would
be like hey happy birthday you know that
kind of thing so I called him just to
kick it and a woman answered the phone
it either is present girlfriend or his
past fiance I forget whatever and she
told me that James was playing
basketball he had heart pains hard chest
pains and he didn't make it so that was
like and that was that's how you found
that that's how I found out and he and I
were together for like nine years
so that I was sad about that because I'm
like I'm like I feel like if he knew
that he was about to die he probably was
so sad and scared because he was such a
he was six four one backer size and
athletes jump shot to kick it ass so I
was really sad but I'm like he he was a
pillar of the community he was a dean at
a elementary school just passed the bar
he was a lawyer this man was you know
new new love life so when he passed that
made me sad but going to his funeral and
seeing him seeing him in an open casket
and he was a very like a materialistic
dude out suit whatever and like that
made me sad I'm like I've never seen
this my big strong athletic man like
that and um and his family they weren't
fond of me because I'm the one who left
him I'm the one who was this and they
were like attack it was a packed ass
Wick this man was famous in his in his
hood and they and I was the one who gave
him a lot of Heartache because he really
was not happy I wanted to divorce him he
tried to off himself all that kind of
stuff it was dramatic so I'm the last
person he wanted to see but when it was
time to say anything in front of the
casket I'm like no I got I want to say
something okay the courtroom hey did you
really because my thing is they had they
these people
the people in this room he only saw at
the family reunion if that I'm like I'm
with this [ __ ] every day
so I didn't give a name by his family
not liking me I'm like you guys love the
judge but guess what when he this
whatever every day of art that was me
and him so I also have like a trip when
it comes to family I'm like you got got
a lot to say but I'm looking at this
dude and he looking at me like how we
gonna figure this out and family is not
around so yeah I forgot where I was
going all this God thank you for the cry
that felt good no you're welcome because
I've been holding that in since last
night like oh God he'll see this or
they'll go around the community like oh
God Becky was [ __ ] I'm more mad that I
had a bad set I was ready to rock that
[ __ ]
you got shook in that room oh and I told
I told Tony that I wanted to cry he goes
you weak you said you got weak and I was
like yeah I wasn't ready to see you in
perform I don't know him well enough I
would love to have him come on and talk
about it I just don't know if I I don't
know if that is offensive to reach out
to someone and say something like that
text him and say is it okay if Ryan hits
you up I mean something a text yeah yeah
it'll text you he'll he'll he'll let you
know whether or not he's comfortable
with it right yes I've seen him talk
about a little bit on like The Breakfast
Club I think he was on yeah yeah
um well you were talking we talked about
was any other significant death and you
said your ex you were sad when he passed
away genuinely yes um what about your
dad when did you you say he was sick did
you get to have any time with him at the
end did you get to have any
conversations any anything I wish you
always wanted to say or I think I think
him getting sick he got It sped up
because he of course probably didn't
tell anybody of the symptoms and by the
time they diagnosed him I was I really
couldn't be in New York much I was
living in L.A trying to work and stuff
so I couldn't come out here much I
didn't have the money to buy plane
tickets the way I would throw them out
now to go wherever I want because you
have to I would be like I really have to
have to to come back so I didn't see him
I didn't um
where I was going Ryan I was asking you
if you had any sort of closure or
conversations
when he died it wasn't there that's one
of the regrets I remember my mom my aunt
called me like three in the morning and
anybody in your family called you that
late you know as always it's gonna be
some [ __ ] and my aunt told me he didn't
make it all I remember is my aunt
passing my mom the phone and my mom's
first words were oh Jackie I don't know
I hit path already and now that took me
because that's when I thought her man
died before I thought daddy died so
because her saying that was me hearing
her saying what the [ __ ] am I gonna do
now so no I just know I didn't see him
before at no closure I remember last I
remember I kissed him on his bald head
like the previous visit during the
holiday so I did get to give was he at
home or was he in the hospital he was
when he died yeah oh in the hospital he
had gotten he had blood clot issues and
they were able to clear up but you have
to get him to the hospital fast and he
got him in his leg I think and that
caused to death so you know but he was
deteriorating slowly with different
ailments and he won I felt like he was
ready to go you know it's just my mom
that I feel bad for because you know
she's someone who gave it all to the
husband you know he handled everything
you know he paid most of the bills and
that was causing I think most of his
depression because he had a lot of the
weight on him and because my mom said to
me I remember one time this made me also
realize that I I'm not we're different
she I was sitting on the floor during
the quarantine watching TV some some and
I remember she said to me because you
want to find a man to pay your bills and
when she said that I'm like I first
thought was judgment like what the [ __ ]
I'm trying to be the man to pay my own
bill right but she comes from a
generation of find a man and a husband
and stop all this yeah you know oh
that's not that wall is nonsense yeah
and I'm like she don't get it then I'm
happy with the hustle the hustle makes
me happy because it's not the job it's
everyone who wants me to have I've had
every job I got a four or five page
resume of [ __ ] this is the only
thing I'm good I'm not the only it's one
it's what I'm good at that I want to
pursue
and it's what I'm best at it's what I'm
best at yeah and I tried a lot of [ __ ]
me too and I've been bad at a lot it's
just a mediocre and bad is it bad or is
it because you didn't like it so you
wouldn't apply yourself okay so that's
what I wanted to say to you it's very
interesting you say that going back to
Career stuff like you said uh that
script I never wrote or whatever and I
think about the same thing too and I'm
like my heart wasn't in it I want to do
comedy but just because I want to do
comedy doesn't mean I got to write the
script for a sitcom I gotta write a
feature I gotta have a this and this
some things you just need to go some of
them are like that's not for me like I'm
never gonna bring juggling into my
[ __ ] act you know what I mean I'm not
gonna bring music into my ACT yeah some
shit's just not for me in comedy so the
things that I feel like resonate with me
that's where I start leaning in hard and
and writing a script actually like the
concept of a sitcom I'll give you a
[ __ ] one sheet all day long but
sitting down and writing the story arcs
and I don't want to do that I don't want
to do that yeah and it's good to be able
to say that because you you kind of come
up in this business thinking I need to
know how to do everything everything and
the older you get the more you're like I
like to perform and if I get a fat ass
job as a writer I'm gonna be bitter I'm
gonna do the job I'll be like but I want
to be in front of the camera and you
have to be secure enough to be like I'm
sorry if it's something arrogant but I
belong in front of the camera and I'm
okay with saying that you know yeah I'd
be like I'd be like years ago saying
well I should know how to do it all but
I don't want to do it all I want to be a
star and be in the writer's room but I
want to be in front of the camera I
don't want to be the writer in the
corner quiet so what is it about your
fiance now that has you so in love what
is it about the qualities in this man
that because you also mentioned outside
we talked about yeah the type of man
your dad was and that sort of sets the
table for you know and if it's a if it's
a good father Yes sort of sets a table
for things you'd like to look for or
would like in a man yourself my father
was a pretty boy like he was an
attractive man and I think that also
made me kind of have a I'm very I'm I'm
looks driven
initially it's what attracts all of us
yeah looks yeah but if you would line up
all of my ex whatever they are they none
of them look alike I got short I got
very fast uh dad bod I got oh my God bod
I have everything because I really do
Vibe I'll be pulled in you know nice
eyes it will vibe in the face good smile
but I'm all I you know the personality
is what makes me want to see them again
but I'm my fiance currently I met him in
college 1989. oh okay he went Community
College I couldn't get into a better
school scene so I met him in Business
Administration class and I first of all
we had a fresh the prom just ended you
know my first September 89 my braces
just got off I was just brand new to the
world of being a woman I went to private
school uniform so this whole new world
of being a really cute girl in regular
clothes and fresh out of high school so
ready to go business administration
class is six foot four inch uh very
dark-skinned jock walks in I remember he
had on a red Champion hoodie red Nike
orange 1989.
he walked in latest Buck there's nowhere
else to said clay so he had to sit in
the front and that was the day I saw him
and I'm like I'm in love with this guy
long story short he was vinegar he had a
girlfriend I was too young I didn't know
what I was doing I was figuring out Kyle
it's like nothing happened to me just
friends never dated or nothing ever
happened this world just classmates then
everybody his girl graduated transfer he
left I stayed there so I stayed College
uh focused to get the degree I don't
know where he went he went to different
schools for basketball military blah
blah blah lost contact met a guy in
college that's the guy I dated for nine
years and then I married him but the
fiance's qualities that so wait can I
stop you for one second I wanted to ask
you that the guy that you eloped with
and ended after one year you had been
with for nine years yes we were a couple
ten total yeah that's naked ten yes so
it wasn't like you'd met this dude and
within a year got married and divorced
you were with this man for a decade yes
that's why we got divorced because it
was already over and I'm still married
okay I married him because I was kind of
like [ __ ] it we've been doing and but
then after I we did it I was kind of
like oops okay yeah all right that was
it so this guy looks you know why he was
my first he was my first exposure to an
actual like real man After High School
all I had were my guys from four years
that you see in school every day and
what do you mean by that he was the
biggest dude I ever seen in my life
because I all I had we had one tall guy
in high school named Patrick black black
guy he went from like five seven to six
four like in one summer he was the
biggest black guy I've seen in my life
all I would say I would go from high
school in the home I didn't hang out
strict family so when I graduated and
went to college he was the first like
I'm like oh this is what the black guy
looked like when they're grown I'm gonna
I like this world so I got a crush on
him from that point on and then I got to
know him through being a classmate but
it was just physical why he came in
contact with me I got in contact with
him when I was in LA I would come home
during the holidays and go say hi if you
know what I mean say what's up well it
was the first time you said hi oh my God
I moved I moved to LA in in 2000 I
probably once a year for 17 18 years the
guy that you're with now yes now
Thanksgiving Christmas what made it
first happen though because you said you
were just friends for so long for that
first time what made it happen I we both
left the college that we met met in and
we lost contact for a while I
transferred to another school but he
came he knew that I had a part-time job
at Bloomingdale's after school he came
to blooming's I was at worked at the
belt counter and accessories he came
there during my shift to get my number
so he could I guess find me he found me
because you remember I worked there and
he knew that I was the kind of person
who kept the job because I had the job
for years while I was in college and he
came to find me and get my number and
saving contact wouldn't commit or ask me
out or ask for anything beyond just can
we hang out so because he wasn't ready
to be a boyfriend back then he was the
hot guy jock who enjoyed his freedom but
I was so whipped at 18 years old with
this beautiful man 19 whatever it was so
I just kind of let him Lead Me and You
Know by the earring
because he was so hot and that was so
inexperienced and I learned what I he
wasn't my first sexual experience but he
was my first good one okay okay so I had
like one or two beforehand teenagers and
it was like Beyond horrible didn't feel
nothing I don't even know what happened
but he was the one who he [ __ ] me and
I'm like oh this is this is what the big
deal is
that's what hooked me in and then over
the years of doing it in this you know
the Scandal is oh I'm coming home but
then when I moved back home I didn't
call him because I knew that once I
called him it'd be on okay but when I
called him I called him with the
intention of picking up the the sex
buddy thing but he was like I want to
try to be a couple
so it was his uh it was his like okay
idea first you ain't going back to LA so
why don't we give it a go so I'm like
well I enjoy hanging out with him let's
see if the joy turns into can I be his
girlfriend and that's how it began
around about three almost three years
ago okay yeah and when did you get
engaged in Hawaii last summer I had a
gig at the Blue Note in Hawaii and uh I
brought him and we were there for like
extended to stay there you know really
expensive to this day I extended to stay
there beyond the booking because it was
Hawaii all I remember is a drunken night
of amazing sex and the next morning he's
like so I guess we're engaged but he's
always been he's always been I've been
the one that's been the coward about
America I did it before but you you said
he's not afraid now are you not afraid
anymore no I'm still scared to death I
have a nice bit in my set where I'm like
I have cold feet women are never allowed
to have it but I'm scared to death when
you're divorced you do go into male or
female whatever gender you do go into it
like oh [ __ ] like can I do this again do
you feel like are you worried is about
this that you're going to bounce after a
year again all right if I'm gonna keep
it real because you're probably never
hear this I thought I'd be one of those
chicks that have four or five husbands I
thought I was down for that
why why everybody was hating on Liz all
she did was keep it moving when she
wasn't J-Lo keep it moving so Idaho I
believe it probably goes to I probably
have a theme over my head of just
running but that's just I don't believe
you should stay somewhere if you don't
if you're not happy I left New York when
they got whack I left here when it got
whack I'll leave a man when it gets
white yeah but 20 years and just running
after six months of being here you you
know
I'm here chill but I did a prison term
out here you did like hiding I was also
hiding and I knew that in New York what
New York is a lot of responsibility I
might I was living out here I had my
little uh Camry my little two bedroom
two bath I wanted more but I was I
thought I'd buy a house in the valley
you know I was going down that path but
then when I realized you know when I got
home was when I realized oh [ __ ]
everybody's old
everyone's health is questionable
including mine I'm in good health but
I'm also older do I want to be I don't
have another 20 to give to another state
I got to be like okay you wanna put down
some roots and I'm doing that now for
the first time at 50 years old putting
Roots down now you know I don't have any
kids but I'll have a stepdaughter when I
marry him because he has a daughter
she's 15 I met her love her so I'm like
somebody told me exactly you're having a
really good second act it's it's
stressful as [ __ ] but it's a second act
also I look at it too Jackie like you
put the time in up front and now it's
paying dividends you know what I mean it
pays out differently for everybody okay
it does yeah and when also yeah you know
but when you put that time and an
investment in at the top it's paying off
for you now if you got love how do you
um feel about being a stepmom I love it
because I I honestly don't know why I'm
not a mom with I don't know why I didn't
let one of these just stay in there I
don't know why I just didn't just try it
you know what I mean that would be a
great mom and some people are like I'm
surprised you're not because your
personality is nurturing and maternal do
you regret it no I don't regret it I
don't believe in regret I'm like God had
a path we don't know what it is and
meeting my new Teenage stepdaughter I'm
like it's plenty of time to you know
cover her and Dazzle and her in pink and
glitter or not whatever she wants you
know what I mean let her be her and are
you do you know her mom I met her mom
for the first time and her the same the
same day how's that her mom was great
her mom is a hard-working entrepreneur
and cool with you being the female
another female influencer she's a big
deal for a woman she seemed cool but I'm
not gonna lie I'm not gonna it came out
of her you know what I mean I'm not
gonna dim my flame I'm fantastic so she
would want to happen this girl she'd
want to have me her daughter's life
because I have because I I did have beef
I didn't meet her for a minute I just
met how long is a minute oh three years
then yeah I well almost three years
we're dating during this time of seeing
each other I remember sitting in my
Toyota Corolla in front of my
girlfriend's house in Bellflower
California late at night before before
the LA got so scary and talking to him
on the phone when he's in New York and
he had something to tell me and he told
me he was kind of gonna have a baby I
remember this 15 years ago and I wasn't
like I was new I was still like bringer
shows and I was sitting in that car bald
crying because I'm like he got somebody
pregnant as many times he's bust off in
me raw
I'm not gonna lie Ryan that's low-key
that is low-key some of the resentment
I'm like the amount of swimmers that
this man has released in me
and not one of them hatched into nothing
I'm still bitter about that to this day
I love his daughter and she belongs
where she is because things happen am I
supposed to but even now because I had
when we first started dating got back
together that was what 48 so I was we I
was we were getting it in and I'm like I
was still on schedule with everything
I'm like I'm probably gonna get and I
had my period was gone for like so long
I was ready to look for preschools and
how long my period was
and it wasn't that it was just menopause
and changing and I was like God damn it
I can't believe I missed it with this
dude was he cool with having one if you
could have one oh yes yeah together
whenever I had a scary period he was
excited and I was low-key like okay I'm
the only one that God can afford to have
a baby
I'm paying for this okay so no but yeah
part of our my sadness is that oh I
could have been my daughter because
she's really a a great person it's too
nice out to be too damn High just
because we've aged out a summer break
doesn't mean we don't need to chill out
ditch the munchies paranoia and potency
of today's weed with dag grass dagrass
is legal organic hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind that grass
CBD products are made with 100 organic
hemp that's easy to dose and the effects
come on smooth they offer a variety of
products from their smokable pre-roll
joints which is what I use as well as
hemp flour and a variety of CBD tincture
drops all that grass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the U.S go to dadgrass.com honeydew to
check out their products whether you're
looking for a new Buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite that grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood right right
now that grass is offering my listeners
20 off your first order when you go to
daggrass.com honeydew go to daggrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's daggrass.com honeydew you just
need to take better care of yourself is
not a response to mental health
struggles you know because you live with
it and sometimes you need something more
to achieve a real and Lasting
breakthrough so maybe it's time you
check out a guided ketamine Therapy
Program from mind Bloom mind Bloom is
the leader in at home ketamine therapy
offering a combination of science-backed
Medicine with clinician and guide
support for people looking to improve
their mental health and well-being mind
Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience alright so here's
what you do I did this actually I've
done two sessions at this point now so I
want to talk about this personally all
right
um I was skeptical at first because I
sit across from people like Josh Adam
Meyers who talk to me about ketamine and
K holes and I told the clinician that
and that's a common misconception of
course so
um I've done two sessions now and I'm
telling you it apps I absolutely feel a
difference there's no doubt I started
with I I took my online assessment first
you take this little test then they pair
you with a clinician had about an hour
discussion with her about what I wanted
to battle and deal with which is anxiety
um then I had a another person who I
talked to before I did the session did
the session had a check-in now I'm on
self-guided all the way till the end
where I check in again and I absolutely
I was thought I was just gonna do two
I'm doing all six of them I absolutely
felt the difference I felt electricity
in my body like it really did uh give me
a good reset so I'm curious to see where
I'll be at the end of these six and I
will let you all know for sure all right
so mindbloom is going to send you a kit
in the mail it's complete with the
medicine the treat materials and the
tips for getting the most out of your
experience after only two sets 87
percent of Mind Bloom clients report
improvements in depression and 85
percent reported improvements in anxiety
and you can Count Me among the 85
percent all right it is time to enter
the next chapter in mental health and
well-being let mind Bloom guide you
right now mind Bloom is offering my
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Honeydew and you use
the promo code honeydew a checkout go to
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that's
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew now let's get back to the dude
so but I'm also open to
um what you call adopting are you I'm
very healthy there's no reason why I
can't give this to us on a baby or if
you want to order okay I was gonna ask
you if you're gonna adopt you one baby
or I would love a baby I would I kind of
have a soft spot for teenage girls
because I remember I had I was a part of
two programs in La where I mentored
teenage girl I've never had one black
girl and one uh Mexican girl Jessica and
Jasmine Jessica yeah j-a-s-i-c never
heard that one and Jasmine and I was
mentoring them a few months we'd go to
the movies and stuff and I loved them
I'm like or separately it's together I
would go pick them up but they're both
in their cribs and I remember Jessica
had issues at her house and she would
ask me like Miss Jackie you know can I
live with you and but because I had a
one bedroom apartment I couldn't leave
the Foster you have to have it too bad
so I was like oh man I thought about it
hard like I could take her right now if
I had somewhere for her to come back to
so if I were to do it teenage girls kind
of made me feel like they could use my
guidance you know what do you think
that's all about your connection to them
because My Teenage life was just so full
of angst why I didn't feel in high
school I was I've always been the funny
girl not the clown but you know
personality and quick quick wit so that
would always make me feel like oh boy am
I getting boys asking me out but they
want to be around me because I'm funny
you know and I always felt like all my
girlfriends were prettier than me and
cuter than me although I I look back now
pictures I'm like I was adorable but in
the moment I use humor as a way to keep
my friends around me and I had fun but I
wasn't I wasn't [ __ ] you weren't
dating at all or anything can you curse
on this yeah we've been cursed out here
that's not the first time
yeah I wasn't I didn't have I wasn't
getting busy when I was in high school
bust the nuts all up in me can you cuss
on it is
I wasn't getting any action in high
school I've never got girl for the
elementary schools in high school they
will come back from uh overnight going
home they have hickeys and [ __ ] and
nobody was touching me I don't know what
it was no none of that stuff no my prom
date was gay
my prom day was a coin
did you know it no I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't know homosexuality
when I was there because it was a secret
in the closet and it was in the 80s so
it was like in and out and I don't know
who was what didn't care I was I enjoyed
my friends so nobody was [ __ ] you
were young whether you're gay or not you
weren't having sex you were too young so
my uh my prom day I remember his name
was Roy and he just he loved me so much
but it wasn't a sexual love and I loved
him but it was an attraction so I
remember and I knew it was gay because
after the prom all of my friends that I
was close to in high school they went to
the hotel and he wanted to go dancing
so we went to a club I think we went
dancing I had a great time but I was
also horny as [ __ ] like why am I not and
then I realized he was never he like
kissing me but it wasn't long tongues it
was always pecking so I'm like he's
attracted to me but he's not he doesn't
want to like be the man in my life and
let and down the line years later I saw
him he had a remember he had a high top
fade and he dyed it blonde he had Hazel
contact I was like oh
that's why I be wearing [ __ ]
but it took years to see him again
because that didn't because again I was
working in retail so I learned about a
little of the gay world I'm like oh and
my friends are like girl you ain't here
I was like no I see none of that I just
liked him but my friends would [ __ ] him
there was a it was a hotel called The
Capri Hotel in New York that was a spot
after the prom that everybody went there
or yes senior prom we got a dirt on a
Wednesday that was a hotel on Wednesday
but nobody was [ __ ] jacket
okay
all right so
you're back in your childhood room at
50. you're engaged yeah and you
mentioned in uh the email you sent over
that at 50 now yeah you started thinking
about a career change I don't want to I
don't want to be a road comic I really
don't I love I love performing I love
that my title in my career on my
Tombstone better say comedian first
whatever else I do you did America's Got
Talent I did I did you did really well
on America's Got Talent semi-finals I
hear that's okay yes
um but if you don't want to be a rogue
comic then what do you want to do as far
as how do you want to do that I want to
I want to act more okay so you want to
be in front of the camera and okay and
have that drive my comedy I'm getting
too stressed out with my my road dates
being like I'll get a good I've had many
a good like turnout on the weekend but I
want a consistent turnout and me being
on TV in spotting places is not enough I
want to be a draw and to be a draw I
realize that I'm gonna have to be a
television personality in some capacity
so I have put it out in the universe I
that I really really want to act more
producing right but I wanted to be in
the world of Television whether that's
streaming or channel four and that's the
goal now because stand up was really
like when I after AGT ended I was
touring I mean like the way you guys do
I was like oh this is what it is real
touring means you are home Tuesday and
Wednesday
if that and that's it until you can
learn to write to be like hey no more
Thursday I'm coming on Friday no more
Sunday and then you can see me on Sunday
and now and I'll I'll take the L too now
they're like no we got to have you on
Wednesday I'm like I don't want to come
here me too I'm not at my mail forward a
[ __ ] I need to be there so long you do
not need to move to a city anymore for a
weekend to build an audience there ain't
nobody gonna be here on Thursday you
don't need to do it that's all for them
yes it's all for them on a thousand
tickets a weekend and you're gonna make
me do five shows well that's not for me
yeah we could have sold two 500 shows on
a Friday night and we all could have
been the [ __ ] out here and then I'm
there on Sunday I come out there and the
audience got 25 and why are we here
y'all could have the chicken fingers and
beer that's why we're here that's why
I'm sitting on the stool you know what's
up [ __ ] you don't deserve the full show
yes the truth I don't mean that I'm
joking but I mean yeah it is the truth
you don't those Sunday people could pack
into the Saturday or the Friday why
couldn't you come last night right you
do nothing today you know and maybe they
couldn't because it was sold out we
should just be putting them all on here
exactly and I will be I'll be honest the
blessing the blessing the blessing is
that I could have my fiance with me with
Road gigs because roller gates for a
woman they're not easy they're not hard
but they're not always safe I don't
always feel comfortable I don't blame
you I don't always feel safe from my
opener in Kansas City had a gun on them
that's I feel safe and scared at the
same time but think about how many gigs
you've had where you go somewhere you
land in Iowa you need the you're gonna
get a ride from the airport it's not a
town car it's some dude named Eric who
used to be on meth and the car ain't got
no record you know if I always gonna be
the luxury it might be the sound guy who
you could tell is high so that's what
every now that you might get that I
don't want that so I like having gigs
where I'm there on the weekend where I
can have my guy with me or maybe and if
it's gonna be a long gig please have you
know I'm I want that because being on
the road alone it's lonely it's sad and
I don't want to do it primarily as my
number one job I have to perform you get
better on the road I've learned that you
learn to rock a room when you're and you
just rock 76 hours or whatever it is you
know so
I the road is necessary but I don't want
to be my life
I don't blame you for that yeah
Well it can't be just your life I mean I
watch Tom and these guys go out and I'm
like man I don't think they're home more
than a stretch of three to five days
whatever whenever I see them post a
calendar I'm like I know I'm low-key
jealous I'm also like no why all of this
it was a time I remember D.L Hughley
there was a cycle he was on where this
this dude was just not home and my first
dog was does he like his wife
how y'all keep the marriage together
unless you like Tony robbers and bring
your wife with you or she's part of your
team but other than that I'm like I
would so like me and my fiance he's
FaceTiming I'm like you have to because
being gone like this you will lose
interest I will I will forget I'm
talking for myself I will be like I'm
always gone I might as well find now I
get how men some men on the road like do
flying girlfriends because they're like
I'm always gone I gotta get laid you
know I don't want to get into them I'm
always gone I get lonely I'm content
performing every now and then and having
the seller as a blessing to
um compensate money when I'm not on the
road so I'm just gig the gig until I can
get on TV because I'm just trying to get
on TV what do you think's your biggest
uh has been your biggest challenge in
your career not doing more of my own
stuff content wise because whenever I do
put stuff up I get a lot of why are you
doing this all the time speaking of Tony
Baker in the beginning this is a happier
thing uh he's he would always be like
why aren't you putting on content and
I'm like so how often he said every
goddamn age and that's him I'm like I
can't do what you'd I can't and I don't
want to keep it real I can do it I can
do everything he does I don't want to I
want to be a star I want to have
cantaloupe all day and I want to have a
nice Green Room honeydew girl yeah I
love honeydew
I want a high amount
that's what's so funny like honeydews
here at the bottom cantaloupes right
here you didn't say strawberries nothing
you said cantaloupe you're not too hard
to please no I'm low maintenance in a
high maintenance way it's very weird
so I'm just the older you get you will
be able to point out what job you want
and don't want and that's why I'm not I
want to be a star I'm funny enough why
why not me that's here's it what look
can you see I have a tattoo what does it
say oh I am enough yeah is that
America's Got Talent on your arm right
yes I got that yeah I was in the middle
of competing I was in Iowa and I'm like
is that where it was Iowa no I was like
oh when I did AGT I still kept my road
gigs around you were going back and
forth yeah because AGT what I did I made
it a part of my itinerary I didn't make
it my life I'm like I'm at The Improv on
Tuesday 82 on Wednesday and that's how I
had fun guy I didn't make it everything
I made it part of my schedule which is
great though because you're staying but
you're staying tuned up the whole time
you have to yeah you're not fine you're
not having to find these stage time
running around town all these sets and
[ __ ] and I truly and I would not I would
actually get gigs also in town to run
things but I truly believe that um Simon
and Howie I had Gabrielle Union and
Julian Huff they were the judges but I
really really really believe that Howie
and Simon can sense when you are working
Entertainer versus you just built it up
put the AGT contest they can tell when
you have it and they can tell when you
are
just this is what you do they can tell
so I'm I kept performing because I'm
like I know these guys can pinpoint
someone who this is their life versus I
want to win this contest so that's that
was my attitude towards the whole thing
all right yeah
um well thank you for coming on this has
been I'm exhausted Ryan I'm sorry I hope
you feel a little better we're not done
quite yet yeah I'm in a great mood I'm
not tired or sick at all you excited
well before we get out of here I told
you at the beginning before we recorded
that after everything we talk about I
would love to know advice that you would
give the 16 year old Jackie fabulous
oh
I would tell 16 year old Jackie fabulous
leave these men alone
I the woman who wrote Eat Pray Love
forgot your name Oprah won Oprah's girls
back in the book club days she's being
interviewed and she said something in an
interview that stuck with me she said if
I had given the amount of time that I
have given to trying to get men to like
me
I could have learned four or five
languages
that's the damn truth and when she said
that I was like oh my God I'm like I
look at it now the amount of energy and
effort I have given to just trying to
with crushes on boys who didn't Crush
back
[ __ ] buddies who didn't want to be more
than that man that I knew I didn't want
to be but I would be with because I was
tired of being lonely like I would tell
16 year old Jackie forget about news and
just be amazing get your degrees get
your jobs make a lot of money earlier
and the men will come that's you know
that's a great advice and it's making me
ask want to ask you another question do
you feel that you've given the best
years of your life to
whatever these empty relationships or do
you believe right now I'm moving forward
is the best you're about to have getting
married because you did say yeah you're
you're scared
I'm nervous because I don't want it to
fail again like I love him so much and
but I also know I know of the flaws that
we both have that could end it all
another time around so I'm also I'm
worried that the things that are
probably
irreparable in terms of his life may
interfere or be a challenge in the
marriage but I have to I'm trying to
understand that I love him so much and
I'm willing to work on it I didn't work
as the first guy first I'm like first I
was like I'm out I could have worked at
it this guy I want to work at it good so
I went to a 16 year old just you know
he's gotta stop worrying so much about
dudes
and I because I'm boy crazy since I
remember High School I mean I was girl
crazy kindergarten just since then me
too once you once you a cute boy I'm
just like oh my God where's someone so I
want to see him I just and I'm still
that way now but now I just keep it nice
and bottled in because I have one guy
good you know I'm I just reached a place
where if you would have checked my phone
my my text messages they're finally all
appropriate
there's no more like hey yeah I saw you
so-and-so that was funny there's no more
I mean this this there but you gotta
scroll you gotta get there so I'm
finally like my girlfriend told me on
the way here she goes you have grown up
you have a mature relationship now I am
happy for you good for you yes I'm
growing up in terms of that well thank
you for coming on thank you Ryan you're
welcome and please promote uh plug all
of it again one more time DC comedy live
uh September 1st to the 3rd I believe it
is but go to Jackie fabulous.com by the
time it comes out you'll see the
calendar will be up to date and um my
comedy album menopause my special
menopause on Amazon Google TV Apple TV
and everywhere you listen to pack oh I
have a podcast relatable with Jackie
fabulous I have over 30 episodes most
recent one I talked to women who are
female Comics who are married uh my gay
friends before that was King and
Thompson from SNL Sherry Shepard so
they're great and it's everywhere you
listen to podcasts so yeah I'm trying to
be like you Ryan and be consistent
that's it that's all you guys I'm good
at all this [ __ ] but I'm not yeah you
are I'm not gonna pay somebody to be
consistent for you you gotta but you
gotta do the job first earn the money so
you can pay the person to help you be
consistent that is part of it I really
don't want to work you want you want to
keep it on
um
[Laughter]
20-something years just to get started
okay in the same age group and we're
like we are just beginning I'm like I'm
just it's a compliment it's more work
now it's more work now every time I hear
Jackie you
[Laughter]
this car has been warming up for 22
miles I think we're ready to play damn
it got carbon whatever poisoning inside
this vehicle has been running so long
well thank you thank you uh as always
Ryan sickler on all social media Ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]